A bat scan done yesterday showed increased tumor activity in my liver, which is very
concerning.
For detox, I am doing coffee enemas three times a week, foot baths four times a week,
sauna, intermittent lease, epsom salt baths one to two times a per week.
Should I change or increase these?
What I would increase is the coffee enemas, I would be doing that daily.
If you were asking back Gerson this question 50 years ago, well, not to be longer than that.
But when he was alive, he would say you need to do coffee enemas three times a day.
So the best way to help flush out the liver, to help with cancer that's metastasized to
the liver is supporting it with coffee enemas.
So I would say increased coffee enemas.
Foot baths, I would leave it alone, sonas.
I would increase the sonas if you have the time to do that.
The sonas help take a ton of stress off the liver because you're helping detox through
the skin.
Remember, your liver is assaulted with amount of toxins that have to process through that
little organ to get out of your body.
If you can take any pressure off of them, the better off you're going to be.
Epsom salt baths are not really detoxifying, maybe a little bit helps, maybe a little bit
through your skin.
They are relaxing and relaxing can help stimulate parasympathetic.
So in that sense, from a neurological stimulation, they can help with detoxification.
So I would do that as comfortable as frequently as you want.
You could do those every day if you wanted to.
But I would definitely increase the coffee enemas.
Try to get to where you're doing that daily.